- OKAY, WE CAN RELAX WITH PEP.
AND THEN ADD A LITTLE
JEFF GARLIC
TO CURB THE ENTHUSIASM
OF THE...
[phone ringing]
LAWRY'S!
[clears throat]
HELLO, SIR!
YEAH, HOW ARE YOU, DAD?
I'M JUST AT THE HOUSE
GOING OVER SOME BUSINESS STUFF.
YOU KNOW, WORKING OVERTIME.
- OH!
SHIPMENT HAS ARRIVED!
KARL TOOK A SALT PELLET
TO THE CHEST
TRYING TO GET IT TOO!
- OH!
DERS, A LITTLE HELP, BUD.
- YES, I--
THIS WEEKEND?
NO, NOT IDEAL FOR ME.
YOU BOOKED THE TICKET?
- OH, [bleep].
WE'RE GONNA RIP HIS HEAD OFF.
- WELL, BREAK THE FACE OFF
OR SOMETHING.
- OKAY.
- NO, THAT WAS JUST, UM--
THAT WAS A TV.
I'M WATCHING SOME...
MAD MONEY,
AND YOU KNOW HOW CRAZY
THAT GUY CAN GET.
HEY, GUYS,
WE GOT A CHANGE OF PLANS.
- GRAB A SPONGE, MAN.
WE GOTTA SOAP THIS BOVINE DOWN.
- YEAH, COME ON, DERS.
DON'T JUST STAND THERE.
WE GOTTA JERK THIS BEEF, MAN.
ADAM?
- YEAH.
- LOOK, GUYS,
MY DAD'S VISITING TOMORROW.
[chainsaw buzzing]
- THAT'S RAD!
- [laughter]
OH, MAN!
WHOO!
OH, YEAH!
VERY HEAVY!
- AAH!
AH-HA-HA-HA!
- OH!
WHOO!
CAN I BORROW
ONE OF YOUR TOWELS?
- YOU'RE ALREADY
USING MY TOWEL.
ALL OF YOUR TOWELS
WERE MY TOWELS.